Attorney General Jeff Sessions is set to
appear today before the Senate
Intelligence Committee the hearing comes
less than a week after fired FBI
director James Comey testified about the
Russia investigation and his meetings
with the president we don't know how
much sessions we'll say in this public
hearing especially about any contacts he
had with Russia and there are new
questions this morning about the
president he is reportedly thinking of
removing robert muller who took over the
FBI investigation of russian election
meddling from Justice Department
officials major garrett is at the White
House with that part of the story major
good morning good morning in addition
the president heads to Wisconsin today
the topic expanding access to
apprenticeships now this jobs agenda
item likely to be overshadowed by the
testimony of the Attorney General and
the apparent and the president's rather
apparent toying with the idea of
dismissing the newly appointed special
counsel I think he's weighing that
option conservative media mogul
Christopher ruddy a friend of the
President breathes life into rumors that
mr. Trump was thinking about firing
Special Counsel Robert Muller I think
he's considering perhaps terminating the
special counsel ruudy was reported to
have been at the White House Monday but
in a statement White House press
secretary Sean Spicer said mr. ruddy
never spoke to the president regarding
this issue
one of mr. Trump's attorneys first
raised doubt on the issue Sunday when he
would not rule out the possibility the
president could dismiss Muller the
president has authority to take action
whether he would do it is enough
ultimately a decision the president
makes adding to the atmosphere of
intrigue this tweet yesterday from Trump
Ally Newt Gingrich saying it's time to
rethink Muller as special counsel in
mid-may Gingrich tweeted Muller quote is
superb choice when I ran and was make
America great again and that's what
we're doing as for the role of governing
the president met for the first time
with his fully confirmed cabinet six
months into his first term mr. Trump's
health care plan faces an uncertain
future in the Senate while tax reform
and infrastructure spending remain in
limbo the president's cabinet
nevertheless was nothing if not fond
it's a privilege to serve I can't thank
you enough for the privilege that you've
given me I want to thank you for getting
this country moving some thrilled
emissions to help you move up your
campaign premises mr. president we thank
you for the opportunity and a blessing
that you've given us to serve your
agenda another item and a disappointment
for this White House a 9th Circuit Court
of Appeals ruled against the president's
most recent travel ban this morning on
Twitter Norah the president said the
ruling comes at a dangerous time and
left two letters out there SC suggesting
to all of us as we've long expected this
battle will end up before the Supreme
Court you know all right major thank you
so much